there's this book called the Bible I
don't know if you've heard of it it's
pretty popular let's talk about it the
Bible is considered sacred to billions
of people around the world and it is
arguably the most well known piece of
literature in history but as you
probably know there is a lot of
different versions of it now the Hebrew
Bible is what is perhaps most
universally accepted it is what's known
to Christians as the Old Testament and
to Jews or in Hebrew as the Tanakh and
whereas the New Testament is something
added later on by Christians and thus
only accepted by Christians the Old
Testament is considered sacred scripture
by both Jews and Christians and the
stories that's contained in them also
serves as the basis of much of Islam as
well contrary to what many may believe
the Hebrew Bible is not actually one
unified book but actually a collection
of many different books including the
five books of Moses or the Torah and the
prophetic books like Kings and Samuel
and Isaiah and Hosea and Habakkuk and
all these as well as the Ketuvim or
writings while all of these are
considered sacred the most important or
exalted of them all is probably the
Torah also known as the five books of
Moses and these books include Genesis
Exodus Leviticus numbers and Deuteronomy
and the stories contained therein from
the very creation and beginning of the
universe and the world and of Adam and
Eve to Noah and the Ark and Abraham and
his family to Moses bringing his people
out of Egypt and receiving the
Commandments on Mount Sinai and then the
nation of Israel walking the deserts for
forty years and then eventually all the
way up to the very death of Moses
himself and his last speech to the
people it's a story that most of us have
heard and that one that serves as the
very basis of the Abrahamic religions
[Music]
but who wrote the Torah and when was it
authored this is a very difficult
question to answer and for a number of
reasons according to Jewish tradition or
Abrahamic tradition generally the Torah
was received or revealed to Moses by God
on Mount Sinai and then written down and
by him but now from a historical point
of view there's no way to know for sure
that this is true we don't even actually
know if Moses existed at all since we
have no real evidence of his existence
outside of the Bible itself however most
biblical scholars today agree that the
Torah was not probably written by one
person in this case Moses but instead
written in fragments by a lot of
different people over a long period of
time the history of the people of Israel
is very uncertain and we have very
little information about its origins but
there seems to have been this kind of
unified Kingdom with its base in
Jerusalem around the sort of 10th or 9th
century BCE that was ruled by a house of
David we have actual historical evidence
to support this claim which which seems
to indicate that at least parts of the
stories of the Bible are based in some
kind of historical truth it is likely
that a unified Kingdom and thus a
stronger state administration and
cultural development led to a larger
production of texts and a scribal elite
centered around the temple scholars like
Matthew Rochelle and Erhart Blum have
examined this period and argues that we
can see a clear break in terms of
textual development around the 8th
century BCE it is thus highly likely
that the first fragments or parts of the
written Hebrew Bible was composed at
around this time now at the same time it
should be remembered that just because
the stories were written down at this
point and that doesn't mean that they
didn't exist before many of the stories
contained in the Torah probably
circulated as oral traditions long
before they were ever written down but
again going back to the original
question who wrote it and how did it
assume its current form well terms of
the first question we simply don't know
but there are a lot of theories about
the chronology of events
popular theory in the 20th century and
still today even if it is contested by
some is something known as the
documentary hypothesis that was proposed
by a German scholar Julius Wellhausen in
this theory it is argued that the Torah
was composed by four main sources over a
period of hundreds of years the earliest
of these is known as DJ's source or
yahwist source the J stands for yahweh
or the misunderstood pronunciation
jehovah which was prominent at the time
and this is a personal name for god
yahweh that is and the text of the J
source is characterized among other
things by the use of this name for God
the date for this text is uncertain some
placing it during the time of the state
of David or his descendants around the
9th to 8th century BCE the second is
known as the e source named after
another of God's names eloheem and is
again characterized by a preference for
this name for God this source is likely
written after the J source and the two
were later combined with J serving as
the main part of the text thirdly there
is the deuteronomist source which
scholars think is responsible for
basically the entire book of Deuteronomy
as well as some of the books outside the
Torah like Samuel and kings this source
is characterized by things like absolute
morality and a lot of laws and things
like that and lastly there is the P
source or priestly source written by
priests and and this sort of logically
is characterized by a focus on a purity
issues of purity and rituals a lot of
rituals as mentioned the J and e source
probably originates in the time of the
first temple in Jerusalem and their
contents thus also reflect this
environment in this period both a D and
the P source however are much later
developments probably from the time of
the exile in Babylon in the 6th and I
think 5th centuries when the people were
forced the people of Israel were forced
out of their homeland
the temple that is the house of God was
destroyed and in exile they were forced
to sort of Forge this new identity and
so
these two texts also very much reflect
that kind of environment this new kind
of thinking the exile period is
incredibly important for the development
of Judaism as we know it it is here that
things like personal prayer and many of
the rituals that we associate with
Judaism comes about as a result of the
drastic change in environments and by
living as a minority group it is likely
that important theological changes were
made at this time as well much
archaeological findings show that in the
Land of Israel and Judah there were many
other gods and idols that were worshiped
alongside Yahweh this is that some
historians to argue that the Israelite
religion pre exile wasn't monotheistic
in the regular sense of the word but
that they practiced manometry are a kind
of Hino theism that is the acceptance
and belief in many different gods but
worshiping only one or considering one
to be more exalted than the others it is
less interesting to see how Judaism
seems to evolve gradually from a
religion much more similar to those of
the other empires at the time that were
mostly polytheistic to eventually become
something very different first through a
kind of Hino theism and then the during
the Babylonian exile especially there is
the shift it seems at least to have very
much more pure monotheism that were then
characterized Judaism going forward from
the time after the Babylonian exile
there is no longer any trace of
monotheism in this culture which seems
to imply that something very important
happened here there was a very important
shift now the Bible itself states that
Judaism was always monotheistic and that
the people over different periods of
time sort of turned away from the true
religion and let us explain it that way
whether you believe this version of the
story or that of historians they both
seem to agree that they moved to a more
pure monotheism was the result of a very
traumatic experience of Exile and the
destruction of the temple so the D and
particularly the priestly source
probably stems from this period when
certain theological ideas and
developments within the religion had
taken place and this was also as I said
collectin in the text there is also
probably around this time that the
different fragments and sources were
gathered together into one text or a
collection of texts and so to speak
something that is very interesting is
that this supposed shift in authors and
time periods can sometimes be clearly
seen in the text of the Torah itself one
of the best examples in my opinion is in
the very opening chapters of Genesis
which describes the creation of the
world and the story of Adam and Eve
scholars believe that Genesis 1 that is
the first chapter stems from the
priestly source and thus a later
development and that most of Genesis 2
the second chapter comes from the J
source which is much earlier so let's
compare them for a second if you read
Genesis 1 it describes how God creates
the world in six days and then rests on
the seventh it describes how he creates
animals and later humans and it's it's
all very poetic but then you move on to
the second chapter and the second
chapter opens with this these are the
generations of the heavens and of the
earth when they were created in the day
that the Lord made the earth and the
heavens and every plant of the field
before it was in the earth and every
herb of the field before it grew for the
Lord God had not caused to rain upon the
earth
and there was not a man to till the
ground and wait a second the story seems
to start again from the beginning and
the rest of the chapters seems to be
give a second version of events that
sometimes even contradict the first to
begin with there is a sharp difference
between what name is used to refer to
God
in the first chapter God is called
exclusively by the name Elohim which is
the Hebrew word for God but suddenly in
the second chapter he's consistently
referred to by his other name Yahweh or
more specifically their combined name
Yahweh Elohim according to scholars this
is a clear break between the priestly
source and the J source the nature of
God also differs somewhat in the first
chapter God is very much transcendent
and he creates the world by his word he
also creates the animals and then he
creates man and as for the genders it
says the following so God created man
his
own image in the image of God created he
him male and female created he them
however in the second chapter God is a
lot more human and described in
anthropomorphic ways for example he
formed man of the dust of the ground and
breathed into his nostrils the breath of
life and man became a living soul
he's also described as walking around in
the garden and when the humans hide he
exclaims where are you indicating he is
not all-seeing in this version also God
creates man first and then only after he
creates the animals and rather than
creating man and female at the same time
Eve is created from the rib of Adam to
be of service to him clearly then here
we have a very clear indication of the
documentary hypothesis at work it seems
clear to scholars that these different
aspects of the texts were different or
written by different people at different
periods and thus they reflect the
different periods in which they were
written the priestly source emphasizes a
more transcendent God something that was
more important in later developments and
also describes things like resting on
the seventh day which is likely a
reflection of the ritual of the Sabbath
that had developed at that time things
like this can be found all over the
Torah especially the first four books
with very clear stylistic language
differences word uses and even sometimes
contradictory versions of the same story
from the sixth century onwards these
texts became more and more viewed as a
single whole and parts outside the Torah
itself was added to the Canon as well it
should be remembered that the
documentary hypothesis is not in any way
universally accepted by all scholars of
the Hebrew Bible many other theories
have appeared over the years especially
in the last few decades but what all of
them seem to agree on is the idea that
the Hebrew Bible was written or the tour
I should say was written by many
different hands and over a time period
of many centuries then developing and
evolving and changing according to the
new kind of ideas and theological
developments that were taking place in
the Israelite religion in any case it
was and remains an incredibly
interesting and import
texts and serves as the basis for some
of the largest religions in the world
and whether or not these critical
historical theories are true or whether
or not the events recounted in the Bible
actually happened or not is not the
important part not to scholars of
religion nor to most of the people
following these religions either it's
always been about what these stories
teach what the emotions they convey and
the symbolic value that they have for
the religious identities of billions of
people around the world the historical
or non historical person of Moses is
only secondary really it is the very
story of Moses and the role that he
plays in the religious history in the
religious mythology that matters most to
Jews Christians and Muslims in the world
both historically and today I'll
probably leave some links to articles
and such things in the description and
feel free to continue this discussion in
the comments I'll see you next time
[Music]